des centaines de voitures et de camions
presque sans interruption du matin
jusqu'au soir
depuis une semaine c'est le quotidien
des habitants du hameau de nouveau alors
ces derniers jours des silhouettes de
cartons au fleury en bord de route
oeuvre de plusieurs riverains en colère
j'ai voulu toucher un peu le les les
gens qui passent pour pouvoir vous faire
voir que font ralentir parce que c'est
des fois c'est intolérable quoi
des fois on voit des camions passaient
ou des voitures c'est 85
kilomètres/heure un pouvoir plus assez
dangereux au quotidien donc voilà donc
maintenant avec la déviation c'est
encore pire parce que c'est sans arrêt
sans arrêt des voitures si les habitants
sont habitués au passage le problème a
empiré
des travaux sont en cours sur la
nationale 151 une voisine pour trois
mois le trafic est dévié ici en
particulier les nombreux poids lourds et
les nuisances qui les accompagnent
bruits de la route qui détrône donc ça
cogne ça plus le camion qui passe quoi
ça fait bouger là ça fait une onde de
choc sur la maison qu'il entend
forcément interpellé par les riverains
la municipalité a prévu des
concertations dans les prochains jours
une solution provisoire est à l'étude en
complément des aménagements déjà
réalisés
ça va être la discussion qui va y avoir
avec département et peel est un donc ce
qu'on peut mettre en place au niveau au
niveau de la traversée boulot voilà mais
bon il ya déjà des deux radars
pédagogiques chemin piétonnier donc déjà
on a on a mis aussi en place des des
passages protégés
à terme la chaussée vieillissantes ou
devrait également être refaite et les
trottoirs sécurisés
mais pour cela les habitants de moulleau
devront probablement patienter plus que
trois mois